hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the first
American chess congress in 1857 it's
Paul Morphy Apple Charles Murphy had
that against the theater or littenheim
we've already seen two games against
between the two of them but only one
game was a part of the first American
chess congress so this is a game from
this is Game two of their match and it's
really a beauty your friends at the bar
in the library are really gonna really
gonna enjoy this one and if you've never
seen this game it's kind of hard to
believe that such a game was played in
those days between such two gentlemen so
without further ado let's check it out
as it really is a wild one yeah so
morphe opens with efore as he usually
does with E 5 by 8 9 9 f3 and Knight to
f6 later han goes for the petrol of
Defense and morphe goes for Bishop to c4
the Arusha gambit so he offers the e4
pawn we have Knight captures on e4 and
now Knight to c3 and now he wants to go
into the mainline well I doubt it was
the mainline back then but Knight
captures D captures and now f6 can be
played for black one of the rare cases
where it's actually okay to play f6 and
the usual tactics that involve
sacrificing the knight here don't work
because black just goes Queen to e7 and
you will not be having any Queen to h5
ideas for example if Queen h5 you just
block and if Bishop here with check you
just move the King Bishop captures here
but in the end you just lose the night
and you lose a piece and you trade
Queens so black would be completely
winning here so after this Knight to c3
move instead of going Knight captures in
c3 now we have b5 Allen Hynek
immediately gives back the pawn he wants
to be be equal in development so Murphy
grabs it Bishop captures on d5 now with
a double attack on the night and now
Knight back to f6 attacking morphus
Bishop Bishop back to b3 and now Bishop
to d6 so like I said listen lion doesn't
want a pawn for at the cost of
development which against Murphy is
definitely the way to go
we have d3 Murphy prepares to develop
some pieces and now castles and here
before going Bishop to g5 or something
morphe doesn't want
Bishop to g4 so he first goes h3 kind of
kind of respecting littenheim littenheim
does the same age six and now Bishop to
e3 continuing development Queen to d2 is
coming we have Knight to c6 Queen to d2
and not Knights the a5 littenheim takes
this opportunity he says okay our King
is still in the center of the board it's
not like you're up that much in
development I'm gonna eliminate your
Bishop and b3 and grab the bishop pair
so morphe without immediately deciding
whether he is gonna castle well
obviously not there but Queen side or
Kings side he first goes g4 and he wants
to start an attack with g5 Lincoln High
first grabs the bishop pair Knight
captures nb3h after Sun b3 and now
Bishop to b7 going for Bishop to c6
although b6 fall by Bishop to b7 also
you know an idea Bishop to d7 and here
instead of g5 right away
Morgan first prepares it with rook to g1
s it doesn't make sense the G file will
open up at some point that you can the
King occupies the same file as the rook
so it does make sense to try something
like this even though for example if if
if Todd had this position I'm sure he
would have gone g5 right away just to
make the attack happen a little bit
sooner but okay rook g1 and now Knights
- h7 grabbing hold of the g5 square but
that's the thing if you've ever I don't
know checked out Josh Waitzkin Academy
for example and chess master
you might remember his his lesson on the
the space left behind so here the night
goes to h7 he controls the g5 now but he
left control of the e4 square so now
morphe grabs it by playing Knight to e4
and now more Fury gains the control of
the g5 square now or the Queen Bishop
and both Knights are controlling the the
g5 square and the g5 can be easily
played so King to h8 of course leave
behind doesn't want his King on the G
file and now more features goes g5 with
h5 not wanting to open up the the G file
and out Knight the h4 makes sense
get the Knights as close as possible to
the black King and now well you could go
for something like a5 start expanding on
the Queen side
maybe some Bishop to b4 ideas are
possible in the future Lenahan goes g6
and there is no reason to do this you're
just giving more few more and more
targets but okay Quinta Ito with this
move Queen to e2 morphe starts to really
show his creativity and you'll see what
I mean by this we've got the c6 and now
F for sacrificing a pawn now the engine
doesn't like more face pawn sacrifice
but it's as a human it's hard not to
like it because if pawn captures then
you get this beautiful diagonal for your
bishop and I mean who wouldn't play that
so e captures an F for our Lincoln Hein
replies with the strongest move
recommended by the engine but now Bishop
d4 check with came to g8 and now the
reason morphe played Queen e2 Knight to
f5 and here you have you already have
some problems your biggest problem is if
you don't do anything
the bishop controls this diagonal these
squares are covered so nice - h6 and the
next thing will be checkmate if you
don't do something but it's not that
easy if you capture the knight then just
Knight to f6 check and the black is
black is done for for example if Knight
captures you just capture here with
chair King moves and the Queen to h5 is
again mate with the rook and Queen
controlling the G and the H file and
it's not not easy to do anything so Ali
tonight again were replies with the best
move morph is king and queen around the
e-file you need to make some room for
the king so rook to e8 we reach the
position from the thumbnail so rook e8
and again what do you play here more if
it goes Knight h6 check now okay it's
not made since the rook vacated ef8
square for the King King the f8 only
move and here morphic castles Queen side
and it's a really tough position really
complicated position even even
complicated enough for you to pause the
video so feel free to pause it and try
to find a good move for black in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
unsporting basically the only good move
Black has here and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show Bishop
captures on e4 was played by Leighton
Hine but this is not a good move Knight
captures and g5 that's a good move now
you have a triple attack on the night
here you will
the defender of the night King g7 in the
future for example or if you block this
bishop can easily pick up the night this
this night cannot ever get back into the
game that's the point and the biggest
point is that after rook captures in g5
which is basically the thing you want to
play you just eliminate the defender and
now after the characters you play Queen
captures in g5 next you can pick up the
night and it's just just a much better
position for black so after this night
capture some g5 move you cannot go for
route captures you have to go for this
endgame Knight captures on f7 King
captures Knight captures and g5 with
Czech Queen captures and g5 now offering
to trade Queen's Queen for a queen so
Queen captures any eight with Czech rook
captures and rook captures and g5 where
more if it would have two rooks and the
bishop against a rook and the bishop
pair so Murphy would be up the exchange
but Layton han would have the bishop
pair it's a very strong bishop pair and
also the past f3 pawn so black black
would definitely be better here but this
is the kind of stuff you have to see if
you want to stop more fee so alyssa
hannon goes for Bishop captures on e4 we
have d captures on e4 and now Queen to
e7 going for four this pawn here but
it's not not not much as morphe finds
quickly finds a way out of it he plays
d5 and now what do you play here well it
does seem like it's a free pawn so why
not why not just capture it and it is in
fact the strongest move so
captures an e5 Bishop captures Queen
captures and now morphe finds a
beautiful move well the only good move
for white as it is so once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this only good move for morphe while i
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on spotting the the
potential Queen sacrifice and for those
who just won't enjoy the show its looked
at b7 point being that now if you
capture here rook captures and f7 is
made as the night covers the g8 square
so that's that's not an option
I'm not gonna tell you what black played
but there is there once again is a move
that's so complicated that
that saves black and can even in some
lines give black the upper hand so feel
free to pause the video and try to
defend this position against morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds so
uh for those of you who were able to do
it I simply do not believe you as this
is this is such a disgusting line I
doubt even morphe morphe saw it but it
just in case some of you did find it
throughly congratulations you are an
amazing player so for those who just
want to enjoy the show its night capture
some g5 and it's it's really it's not
easy to find a move like that
point being white place rook captures in
g5 and now you cannot capture the route
back because again you're getting made
it route captors on f7 so the move you
had to find his first nightcap for some
g5 route captors and Queen f6 and this
gives the black sufficient defense now
Morpheus Queen is hanging and well his
looks not hanging a cecil has to deal
with with the threats of checkmate so
queen f2 and now black goes for rook to
e7 he doesn't allow of course rook
captures here rook captures on e7 Queen
captures on e7 still attacking the rook
in the rook to d5 but now rook to e8 and
yes more fees up a piece but how is that
Knight ever coming out the the point is
he's not here you have a problem the
queen is coming to e1 and there's not
much you can do about it so you could
grab some material Queen it captures on
f4 quinta II won with Czech rook to d1
blocking Czech and Queenie three now
with Czech you force a queen trade
captures captures and now next move
you're just gonna play King g7 and
you're gonna pick up the night so of
course white wants some counter play
threatening to capture on f7 so rook the
e7 captures captures and now Knight the
g8 with Czech hoping you go after the
night so the knight can wiggle his way
out
but King e6 and now you are winning back
the night King d2 you can play f5 you
can go King III king of seven and now if
you don't want to lose the night you can
at least pick up one of the points night
checking here characters characters and
after this we get this position where
it's equal material well it's not equal
zero black
up upon and White's pawn structure is a
bit messed up so if such a line happened
listen I would have a completely winning
endgame but it's uh like I said I mean
tonight characters followed by Queen to
f6 if you if you you know people who who
see this stuff don't watch my videos
I'll tell you that much but yeah of
course a little I didn't see it he
played Queen to g7 I just defends the
pawn here and also opens up an attack
against Morpheus Queen but now there's
there's not much for morphe to do quincy
for morphe adds a third attacker to the
f7 pawn rook to e7 blocking and now rook
captures on e7 King captures and rook to
e1 with check and it was in this
position unmoved 29 that Theodore lived
in Hine resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so at least
it's 29 moves a previous game lasted 19
moves so with the black pieces lasting
10 more moves against Murphy not not a
bad start to the match so here he
resigns because if you go back 25 is
made that's the point a rock covers this
night covers g8 the King has nowhere to
go any other any other squares are also
bad if King d8 you just got Queen d5
check King c8 rook to e8 is mate and if
you start marching the King down the
board King D 6 it's a bit of a longer
one but still Rudy one check in East 7
Queen captures on c7 check King e8 and
now finally rook e1 check King goes back
and again Queen to c5 is mate because
these two squares are covered so really
really impressive stuff by both of them
but after looked at e1 at least in Hein
resigned and Morphy takes a lead in the
match 2 to 0 so really incredible stuff
like I said I'm sure your friends at the
bar and the library will be really
impressed with this one or this one be
sure to show it to them and yeah also
something I wanted to show you it's part
of the candidates tournament that's well
about to be played there's the yesterday
you've seen a job of statement regarding
why he withdrew from the map from the
tournament and here is MBL's reply about
the whole situation so you can maybe
pause the video and check it out if you
want
or if not if you don't enjoy it that way
I will put a link in the description
below it will be the first thing you see
we'll take you on MBL's blog slash
website thingy and you can read more
about it there so once once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank goo not Houston Mickelson jelly
will deers William McKee already Stalin
and garni Barca dalian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Paul Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend